I didn't want to initially give a talk
but like I
I have realized that it's been like
today exactly 10 years since I
proudly announced the
the formalization project at Kiko.
So in
I think it's been 10 years.
Yeah, so today is July 10th.
Also
I I should probably say a little bit of
a story but like I I didn't even know
that Michael would schedule me for
today. I just
And Prophecy is a good analogy. And
I I just wanted to say a couple of words
about like this whole landscape and what
I think
about like the past, present, and some
surprises that that were on the way and
I should say that I will not speak like
too much about LLM based formalization
because we have lambda for that and for
conjecturing with LLMs we have more more
talk I I think so.
Don't don't expect
some craziness.
I I tried to sort of like I took it as
an opportunity to slightly sort of
organize my
my
in
in in the history of of of this times
and also why I sort of felt uh
that
things weren't going in the in the right
direction when I declared this project
10 years ago.
And like you can obviously correct me.
I I don't claim uh super historical
expertise on this. So so you you have
these I don't know like 10
to 15
uh events I would say in the history
of
like sort of human friendly
automated maybe formalization
uh starting really
with this Yushkevich's
work on
natural deduction which is very very
much
uh very much sort of embodied in the in
the desire
of style.
And I I I tracked the first thing into
John McCarthy.
And I think J. Alan Robinson was his PhD
student but correct me if I'm if I'm
wrong. Who remembers the history?
So
I like he really thought
that he he would be checking natural
language textbooks back in 1962 and 19
63. So these
these pioneers they were pretty crazy,
right?
Can I add one thing on that one? I mean
people don't mention here the student
program of of Danny Bobrow who was doing
this Adam work between informal and
formal in 1964 is his PhD thesis. So
it's kind of just
Yeah, so so like I said I don't claim
any completeness. I also think that
Andre could could say and and his
seniors
uh from here should should should
do some full time work. Uh
a a lot of studies and we had it 10
years ago in in the Western Electric was
done
a bit about the side system developed by
the Push Cup team.
Uh and like that was very much parallel
I would say to to to to this John
McCarthy development in the Western and
is very unknown still on side social
like that.
Uh and then then obviously we have Andre
Trybulec getting into it in 19 73. And
then like that's one of the project
that's the last.
I I I would say so so these are the
things so like for example Andre was
sort of initially some sort of a
linguist / AI guy but he quickly
uh sort of went with with the sort of
Abrahams
Abrahams' conclusion that checking like
the full natural language is is too
crazy but but we
we don't have the tools for for for for
the time so he really went in this
direction of controlled
natural language. Then
I I again I don't know much about
Donald Simon's PhD thesis. Maybe Shankar
uh yeah. Because this was I think Andre
would have done so, right? Yes.
And that that again seems like a very
amazing
Um yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
So so so that was again like like like
this very direct attempt like like write
parser for
like controlled or maybe even like
unlimited natural language manually
write and try to prove check it with
some with some manual inference rules.
He was working on the the back end of
the material.
So so then
like I guess everybody knows this E and
P but it's just structured proofs. I I
didn't know much about how how Arnauld
got into grammatical frameworks. My
estimate is that it's 1990s on on words
but like yeah.
Uh
then then
you know at some point Macario's
rewrote Isabelle basically like like the
the Mizar people are joking that it's
just Mizar, right?
And I I think the the
the the big thing which I learned from
the Mizar guys
is that you shouldn't try to do some
sort of natural language
parsing like Andre Trybulec was
extremely skeptical about it because he
knew the work of Klaus Sena which was
done I don't know maybe Michael knows
more about it because this was done in
the Omega Omega group. No.
What in Erlangen? Oh in Erlangen but he
did work with Omega. Erlangen parser to
be something. He did work with lots of
things.
Okay. Not not really the Omega. No.
Related to Michael. Okay.
So so so I I would say this
this is probably very much worth reading
because it's it's a big exploration.
Can we can we do this stuff manually?
And like I said like when I started to
look at Mizar for other reasons
basically to steal steal this data set
for machine learning of automated
theorem proving
they they were extremely negative about
try trying this sort of
automated for formalization.
And like then again then there is Andre
working on SAT but I think it has always
been like kept in the controlled natural
language domain, right? Like it's it's
very
and then there is Peter and then there
is Mohan, right? And and with Mohan I I
I talked with Mohan back in 2008 when I
visited Ladek.
And I I was both impressed and and a bit
because on one hand you you have this
very smart guy and on the other hand he
again wanted to do it manually. Like he
wanted to write manual parser.
So sort of
it's really
at at some point I I I said like like no
like
we we have to do it differently.
Uh so
so back in 2004 where then I was still
stealing this Mizar data
then they actually did formalize this
compendium of continuous lattices
from like 60% already
by by the time.
And like at that point it was so so
crazy for some people to believe that we
could try to like statistically
translate LaTeX to to formal language
that actually they did give me the LaTeX
sources.
But I I haven't used them for for like
10 years.
And like then
I would say they basically for for 10
years nothing was happening.
And I I I really started to wonder will
I die and people will be still writing
like manual parsers? Like is this the
Like Piotr Rudnicki at some point
at this interview in some Polish
newspaper was saying in 300 years we
will formalize mathematics. So like
okay, well.
So so so so yes I I I simply decided
that even though we have done very
little we we simply have to declare this
project that like we will be doing what
for example Google Translate was
becoming very good at at the time. And
this was before they they actually put
uh language models at Google Translate.
Uh and and that's basically some sort of
statistical machine translation to to
and combinations with with all all the
stuff
uh semantic weapons that we have like
type checking, theorem proving, etc.
So so I
I I in my mind like there there are like
a bunch of things that that somehow
interact together.
And like today like everybody thinks
large language models will will do it
all and we will uh fully translate
natural language to to formal proofs but
like you have just seen I don't know. I
still
like if you are still struggling with
large language models and I guess we
will see more talks about about that.
But then there there is this controlled
natural language.
And I I I think it's it's it may be like
a very important weapon. So for example,
last year
we did a
very small project on common sense
reasoning.
And what turned out to be like a very
very good trade-off
was to
if you have natural language
ask large or small language model to to
simplify it, to to split it into small
sentences, make them simple, remove like
the fancy vocabulary.
And once once once you have it, it's
sort of approaching the control natural
language area, for which you can even
attempt to like force something like GF
or something portal or map map project
etc. So so I think one
one thing that we should be exploring
is like at least this today's
generations of the statistical
machine learning tools.
It At least my experience in the last 10
years has been
that we some tasks are simply too
ambitious. Like you shouldn't go for
example for some fully elaborated Mizar
text from from high tech when you can go
from the unelaborated
Mizar text where for example the hidden
arguments and
the type
I I added then by the elaborator. So so
if you if you can sort of very much
simplify the the task
that you are giving to to these
statistical methods
the whole pipeline becomes better. So so
I I I'd say like one
one note like about how how to how these
things can interact is is that like we
we are not crazily ambitious and and we
will basically have have these for
example use of map reduce, right?
Map reduce in the middle or something
like that.
Another folder again like people today
like with the sort of lean revolution
I like several people asked me privately
could you do or ask people
could you do a formal to formal
translator from I don't know lean to
right? Like we want to steal math
flip because it's very good etc.
So so again like
for example people did like these
pretty
surprising I I'd say
um
alignments
sort of
statistically simultaneously between
different proof libraries.
And
you you could sort of try to
somehow
do the formal to formal if you if you
are aiming for some crazy future where
we will be very easily translating from
Isabelle to lean to Mizar to to
whatever.
You you will
you you could say that this will this
will all be done by statistical machine
translation. But but again like for
example Mario has this lean three to
lean four, right? And and that that
could probably be extended to I don't
know lean to or to lean or
whatever.
So so again like I'm
I'm somehow seeing this thing as some
part of the sort of design space where
some of it like GF, right? Like we could
have like GF for
I don't know Mizar to map reduce, or map
reduce to Mizar or whatever.
So
again like do we do we have to do it all
by
like large language models? Or for
example could we
could we for example use the the AI that
we have today to automatically design
these translations, right? Like to to
for example have a GF translation system
that that is sort of explainable and and
goes back and
back and forth.
Yeah so so I I guess these are some some
sort of three to four things
that
that are somehow in
in this
in this area and I will I will not go
through all the slides but the way
but like I will
I'll just say like what I'll say in
these 10 years have have been
probably the the biggest surprises for
me. So so I I guess
maybe the first one and I'm I'm
to the people who haven't seen it but I
think many of you have seen it.
Show you this sort of
probabilistic context free grammar that
they did
as as as the first approach in in 2015
where
it's a picture
this
this demo which only takes one minute.
So I I think many of you have seen it
multiple times. So so you sort of write
an informalized statement and then you
on the fly today we'd call it retrieval
augmented generation create
a grammar probabilistic context free
grammar
which
the informal statements
and
type checking them like in the
probabilistic context free parser.
There there there is the whole in the
middle of the type checker.
And some limited version of it. And then
you are sort of sending it to to
basically to to the whole hammer that we
that we created
so uh
so so this was um
go back.
Uh
this was probably the first prize
that even though this was produced by
informalization like it's a sort of
synthetic data etc. etc.
The the
the grammar that we created completely
automatically like just just from the
corpus by the probabilities from from
the corpus
was really very good in in in this task.
The the type checking methods that that
were put inside the PCFG parser were
extremely useful like they were really
improving the job efficiently. And and
then what also surprised me is that like
these things were sort of occasionally
coming up with new conjectures that we
could prove for example by by by the
hammer. So so for example it would take
the informalized statement interpret it
differently and and then it could
actually prove it. So instead of a
theorem for
square matrices we would prove a theorem
for rectangular matrices just by by the
wrong parsing.
So that was the surprise.
And I I I somehow still think
that like these
and maybe there's some sort of a bridge
between what Arnd I was showing and
Peter was showing and what we will see
with the large language models
is somewhere in the middle.
Like it is statistical, it is sort of
initially
produced by a machine like the parser
but it's sort of in the explainable
realm. So so so maybe what once you
generate the the grammar from some some
some corpus you can go sort of in the
Arnd
direction and somehow tweak the grammar
to your liking, maybe limit it, get get
rid of the worst possible cases. And I
think maybe today we could do this even
like with the bigger guns that we have
in in the LLM like take I don't know
Isabelle and ask
ask for reasonable grammar from from
that line. So so I I think that that is
the space of solutions that are
explainable. Maybe they have some
probabilistic thing to it but they are
not as crazy black box as as the full
scale
neural neural machine.
I probably um
mentioned the
people thing
already.
Oh I better not do this one sorry.
Yeah. So so so what also very much
surprised me and that that may be sort
of a new thing for people who don't know
it.
Yeah. So so this is about what he
before he got into home and hammer
or maybe simultaneously
was working on alignment between
libraries
which weren't weren't like purely
statistical. They were really like a
nice combination of what you could say
statistical and symbolic methods
in in the sense
that you basically take two libraries
like I don't know whole light or whole
four Isabelle etc.
And you
characterize each symbol
by by the list of lambda abstracted
properties that hold
about that symbol. And you you do some
sort of reasonable probabilistic
weighting like TF-IDF like if some
property is valid about every symbol it
shouldn't be too
too too important as a as a
characterization of the symbol.
And then just by doing this and and
having some some sort of fixed point
algorithm
he he could really surprisingly well
align multiple proof assistant
libraries.
And
like
again like there there there is this
aspect of like like fine maybe today for
example we have this graph you will not
verify by medical chart, which is like
fully signature independent, and it's
very good in understanding
uh
and citing theorems from one domain to
to to another. But like maybe we could
uh
have
as as a complement to to all all of
these sort of either manual or like very
neural black box methods,
more of these like
mhm transparent semantic methods, which
so if you you you cannot really see so
well in the in the sort of neural
language modeling
world.
Uh so so if you don't know it, then I
would recommend it to to all all such
people interested in in this in this
space, too,
uh to to look at it.
I I would say at some point like with
Sean we we did this first
basically neural autoformalization on
the on the desire uh synthetic data set.
And like this was really like I I had a
couple of surprises in my research life
so far, and then this this was
definitely ranking pretty high,
because I I gave Sean a data set of 1
million LaTeX to Miz A formula that were
synthetically generated, and he started
to play with different neural
architectures.
And the the performance went from crappy
and like that's what I expected, to very
very good.
And like at at that point, like this was
2018, I I was sort of sold. I I I saw
that the neural people, like like I I I
know that today many people are annoyed
by the neural people by the hype, but
I'm also annoyed.
But like at at that point, I saw that
there there is real
very valuable research done done here.
But for example, the introduction of
attention in already in LSTMs, I'm
sorry, bidirectional LSTMs
makes huge performance jumps in in in
these neural architectures. So so I
would say
uh
it's it's very hard today to to maintain
some balance of your mind, but if you
if if you if you try, this is after the
spam filtering, this is really like a
very interesting landscape of of
solutions.
Typically, you need to try it yourself.
You you you sort of can't believe what
some high-profile papers say, because
there there there is really a lot of
corruption, like training on testing
data, etc. But but like really some some
of these techniques that people develop
in in language models are extremely
uh powerful.
And yeah, okay, let me skip to the end,
cuz Valeria is nervous.
Uh so um
So I I I will be at AI one month from
now, and I'm supposed to tell tell these
AI people what's the future of of formal
formal mathematics.
And three years ago, I I sold them
really this vision. Like like it was
like what Johan Commelin was saying,
that he's still talking to us in in
natural language.
I I think
I think that this still really like like
I I had these these bad surprises given
to me by by this freak about how much we
want to formalize in how how much time.
But like today, I would be even like
bold enough to to sort of sharpen it by
by saying that like the combination of
all all these methods that we are seeing
here, for example, in in 10 years will
really
like the way YouTube is now transcribing
transcribing our talks into natural
language, we will have tools that will
be transcribing the math talks in into I
don't know approach or maybe even Lean,
I I I don't know. Like but I I I would
say
may maybe the messages that I am
sort of
very pleasantly surprised how how the
last 10 years developed, and I'm sort of
very happy that
the Lean people sort of forced me to to
go there by basically telling me yes, do
do this project. So that's thanks.